[Musique]
bien on débat sur france 24 on va
revenir sur l'attentât racistes commis à
boffa l'eau dans l'état de new york aux
états unis attaque qui a fait dix morts
et trois blessés samedi dans un
supermarché de la chaîne topps d'un
quartier afro-américain de la ville
l'auteur de l'attaqué est un
suprémaciste blanc de 18 ans il est armé
d'un fusil automatique avant le massacre
il a publié un manifeste raciste de 180
pages où il se définit comme fasciste
raciste antisémite et il se réclame de
la théorie complotiste du grand
remplacement il indique aussi s'inspirer
du massacre perpétré par un suprémaciste
blanc qui avait tué neuf personnes dans
une église du quartier noir de
charleston en 2015 joe biden est sur
place il est à boffa l'eau où il a pris
la parole pour dénoncer la tuerie
raciste qui est du terrorisme a dit le
président américain le suprématisme
blanc est un poison at il ajouté et est
accompagné de son épouse jill et il a
rencontré également des survivants alors
que représente la théorie du
suprématisme blanc aux états unis cette
attaque raciste ouvre-t-elle une
nouvelle fois le débat sur la vente
d'armes dans le pays quel impact
finalement cet attentat at il dans la
campagne à quelques mois des élections à
mi-mandat que propose joe biden on va en
parler avec mes invités j'ai le plaisir
d'avoir à mes côtés françois durpaire
bonsoir bonsoir historien spécialiste
des états unis auteur de la bd le
dernier livre et c'est aux éditions à
glénat bienvenus françois encore une
fois sur notre plateau en face de vous
mahboula soumahoro bonsoir soir
maîtresse de conférences à l'université
de tours spécialiste des états unis et
des études africaines américaines
bienvenue à vous nous avons avec nous on
duplex de new york john rich macarthur
bonsoir directeur du rapport aux
magazines et ancien reporter ou wall
street john en bienvenue à vous
avant de démarrer ce débat on va écouter
justement joe biden qui vraiment à
évoquer ce terrorisme comme il l'a dit
on écoute tout de suite
ce qui se produit ici
c'est du terrorisme
du terrorisme intérieur
l'idéologie de la suprématie blanche n'a
pas sa place aux états unis ne rien dire
c'est être complice ce que nous ne
pouvons pas rester silencieux
et avant d'en débattre on va redonner un
peu de contexte avec ce sujet que vous
allez voir puisqu'on va on sait très
bien que cet attentat on rappelle au
moins deux autres aux états unis au
texas et en caroline du sud inès
olhagaray
de sa soeur célestine il ne lui reste
plus que ce portrait et les souvenirs
des jours heureux
toute une famille meurtrie depuis la
fusillade qui a frappé la ville de
buffalo samedi dernier
johan se trouvait aussi au supermarché
lorsque la sai on ya fait irruption
elle a échappé de peu à une mort
certaine
je pensais qu'elle était encore derrière
moi tout le monde me disait d'aller me
cacher à l'arrière du magasin pour
sortir par une autre porte
il y avait quelques personnes je leur ai
dit que je cherchais ma soeur
ce n'est qu'après la tuerie de masse
dans une vidéo postée par le meurtrier
présumé sur les réseaux sociaux que la
famille tchané a appris son décès
j'ai reçu la vidéo et je le regarde et
il a tiré sur ma mère une première fois
je les ai vues allongées sur le sol il
est revenu
il a rechargé son arme il lui a tiré à
nouveau dessus a manqué
dix afro américains ont perdu la vie
dans la fusillade un crime à caractère
raciste selon les autorités le
suprémaciste blanc à peine âgé de 18 ans
est un adepte de la théorie complotiste
du grand remplacement dans la communauté
noire de buffalo le deuil a laissé place
à la colère et un sentiment d'insécurité
être un homme noir aux états unis pas
seulement à buffalo c'est être une cible
au quotidien la cible des policiers des
suprémacistes blancs on est constamment
visé j'ai peur pour ma vie je déteste
dire ça mais c'est quelque chose qu'on
vit tous les jours dans cette société
en août 2019 vingt trois personnes dont
une majorité d'hispaniques avaient été
tués dans une fusillade à el paso texas
9 afro-américains trouvé la mort en 2015
dans une autre tuerie de masse racistes
à charleston en caroline du sud
françois durpaire ce peyton jen tron qui
est donc le tueur est ce que c'est un
suprémaciste blanc comme dillon ruf en
caroline du sud comme brendon brenton
parente dent contre les deux mosquées on
se souvient donc dans la ville de
christchurch oui exactement est en fait
il
s'inscrit en fait dans cette lignée là
c'est un petit peu le cercle vicieux
c'est à dire que aujourd'hui ce qui se
passait quand ils commettent ce type de
crime ils s'inscrivent dans des crimes
précédents et il appelle à des crimes
futurs ça a remarqué que le tueur de
buffalo il avait une caméra sur son
casque et cette caméra c'était destiné à
être en live streaming sur twitch pour
pouvoir est bien inspiré il ya deux
choses faire du mal mais aussi inspiré
d'autres blancs pour dire aux blancs
vous êtes menacés très clairement on
passe d'un rassis me classique j'allais
dire américain le blanc est supérieur un
racisme on va dire qui est inspiré de la
théorie du grand remplacement qui est
une théorie française on le rappelle
mais qui a des inspirations aussi à nos
efforts notamment américaines et qui dit
leblanc non seulement est supérieur mais
le blanc est menacé de submersion on le
verra plus tard c'est pas uniquement ces
tueurs qu'il le pense c'est diffusé dans
la société américaine et de grandes
chaînes de télévision comme fox news qui
ont paru extrêmement souvent on y
reviendra sans doute sont d'ailleurs
venir mahboula soumahoro est ce que
cette théorie du grand emplacement est
de plus en plus répandue aux états unis
et c'est vrai qu'elle était scellé ses
listes d'extrême droite renaud camus qui
ad'abord populariser cette théorie elle
est devenue presque une théorie
américaine aujourd'hui je sais pas si je
j'aborderai là les choses de cette façon
puisque je dirais que les états unis
n'ont pas eu besoin de la théorie du
grand remplacement telle qu'elle a été
formulée depuis la france hexagonale et
que en plus si on accepte cette théorie
là on passe sous silence des siècles
d'histoire étasunienne et donc quand on
parle de la de la communauté africaine
américaine qui a été visée dans ce cas
la danse est un acte terroriste quel
serait leur emplacement que
constituerait une communauté qui est
présente sur le territoire qui allaient
devenir les états unis depuis 1619 oui
mais celui qu'il utilise et réduire de
10 les ont peut on peut se dire c'est
que vraiment une ignorance totale de
l'histoire puisque autant dans le
contexte européen et dans le contexte de
l'immigration post coloniale on peut
avoir des frayeurs complètement
injustifiée de renversement
démographique autant lorsqu'on parle de
la communauté africaine américaine on
parle d'une d'une communauté qui est
indigène au aux états unis d'amérique
c'est à dire dont la présence précède la
constitution même de l'état-nation états
unis c'est à dire que les africains
américains sont la ddt avant l'arrivée
des vagues migratoires donc ça me
surprend que le tueur ait pu utiliser
parlant ça ne sert à rien mais c'est ça
montre séance est encore la preuve de
l'ineptie constituent
ces six analyse historique john rich man
car comment expliquer la téléco de cette
théorie du grand remplacement est ce
qu'aujourd'hui on peut dire qu'elle
commence à être banalisé aux états unis
grand remplacement ça a débuté il ya
très très longtemps
y est beaucoup de gens paranoïaque aux
états unis mais les massacres contre les
noirs il y en a eu
souvent au début du 20e siècle à chicago
à tout ça dans l'oklahoma
c'était pas forcément avec des fusils
biya y ait eu des centaines et des
centaines des milliers finalement de
noir assassiné
tout au long du bien surtout la première
moitié du 20e siècle donc c'est pas
nouveau ce qui est nouveau ici c'est
peut-être la façon dont les tueurs se
prononce sur internet avant de faire de
leur travail dégoûtant
celui ci a fait son truc avec le live
streaming sur sur un ordinateur ce qui
était absolument hallucinant et ça c'est
à mon avis tant que je sache c'est
nouveau de présenter de ce présent de
prononcer sa laine
actuellement pendant qu'on qu'on tire
c'est extraordinaire et comment
expliquer ça je ne peux pas l'expliquer
donc je vais pas et c mais ce que je
dirai davantage ou en plus c'est que le
grand de remplacement c'est encore du
point de vue politique c'est pas nous
c'est pas nouveau dans le sens que il ya
très longtemps pas tellement longtemps
quand il y avait des grèves aux états
unis des années 20 des années 30 on
cherchait à embaucher des noirs pour
remplacer les blancs pour briser les
grèves par exemple alors cette parole ja
ça existe depuis très très longtemps
ça existe depuis serré dans l'adn
américain american français dur permet
la laissez moi oui joe biden a tout de
même je fait réagir françois durpaire
john rich joe biden a tout de même parlé
de ce poison du suprématisme blanc donc
comment de cette théorie d'ailleurs du
suprématisme blanc comment est-ce qu'on
peut la définir pour les spectateurs
prêts massifs mont blanc très clairement
il est en augmentation forte ces 55 %
d'augmentation des groupes suprémacistes
blancs entre une période très très
courte en 2017 2019 et c'est vrai que ce
qui structure
suprémacistes blancs c'était la question
très ancienne de la supériorité de entre
guillemets la race noire ce qui se passe
la race blanche ce qui se passe c'est
que c'est pas une lubie le livre de
chevet de stephan miller qui est celui
qui a élaboré les la politique anti
migratoire de trump c'est le camp des
saints c'est le livre de jean raspail
1973 bien à vos renaud camus et son idée
c'est là contre colonisation maboul a
évoqué le fait qu'il n'y a pas de bon
pas parler c'est très difficile de
transposer ça à l'amérique sauf que
qu'est-ce qui se disent et c'est pas
uniquement les tueurs c'est je le
voulais foxnews je vous donne un chiffre
incroyable un américain sur trois
aujourd'hui croit en cette théorie
conspirationniste je sais pas comment on
peut la qualifier 1 sur 3 1 sur 3 un
américain sur trois croient qu'il ya une
politique des démocrates pour faire
appel à l'immigration afin de faire des
gains électoraux
vous auriez un républicain sur le
plateau je vous garantis stéphanie il ya
une forte chance pour qu'ils vous disent
oui pas exactement ça et c'est beaucoup
plus facile à faire passer que de dire
aujourd'hui en 2022 les blancs sont
supérieurs ils vous disent nous sommes
menacés et ils vont vous rajoutez en
2050 d'ailleurs le groupe blanc sera
minoritaire aux états unis donc il ya
une réalité de cette idée est d'ailleurs
cette réalité là vous la voyez elle et
les trois gros crime revenir le crime en
2019 dans une synagogue 11 juifs tués au
pourquoi parce qu'il laisse rentrer des
envahisseurs c'est ce que dit le tueur
l'année d'après el paso on tue des
hispaniques parce qu'ils sont des
envahisseurs et aujourd'hui dans les 180
pages on explique qu'il y à un génocide
de la race blanche on explique qu'il ya
une extinction de la race blanche et ont
fait le plus de publicité possible à ce
crime pour réveiller la race blanche qui
va être balayé ce qui est comme le dit
ma boule à une folie intégral d'abord
parce que démographiquement ça ne tient
pas la route et puis surtout parce que
toutes les personnes qui rentrent aux
états unis on parle pas des afro
américains qui sont là depuis l'origine
mais s'intègre s'intègre aux états unis
d'amérique et ça le grand emplacement
n'en parle pas du tout que ce soit ici
d'ailleurs ou partout ailleurs mahboula
soumahoro on parle d'un loup solitaire
lorsqu'on parle par exemple de sept
assaillants qui raconte donc dans son
manifeste s'être plongé en mai 2020
après un extrait m'ennuie je cite duo
confinement contre le colis de 19 dans
quatre tchane faute chan qui en fait un
forum utilisé par l'extrême droite donc
c'est serait un loup solitaire qui
auraient utilisé ce type de forums
nous solitaire c'est ce qu'on sait ce
dont on parle souvent quand on parle par
exemple de la question des violences
policières raciste non je pense que là
on parle quand même d'un jeune homme de
18 ans donc c'est un jeune homme et
c'est peut-être le séduit comment dire
le symptôme de quelque chose de plus
large à 18 ans va pas construire cet
homme comme un seul jeune homme comme un
maître à penser ou comme quelqu'un qui
aurait eu le temps et et l'énergie
d'opportunités de penser les grands
problèmes du monde et les problèmes des
états unis non on parle vraiment d'une
expression d'une pensée raciste ancienne
politique là on a une résurgence de ce
qu'on appelle le suprématisme blanc aux
états unis mais donc il ya une
résurgence il ya une résurgence mais
s'active mais sais tu comment dire cette
histoire lé 13 ans très ancienne mais
yens aux urgences tout de même assez
comique n'est pas nouveau mais ce que
c'est ça qui est un peu nouveau en veine
ce qui est nouveau c'est c'est la
configuration aujourd'hui c'est voilà
l'accès aux armes l'accès aux armes
automatiques on va revenir hanter c'est
internet c'est à dire que tout comme
dans les années 50 ou 60 le mouvement
pour les droits civiques avait bénéficié
de l'intérêt médiatique et de la
diffusion des images de violence du sud
dans le reste des etats-unis dans le
reste du monde lassé des suprémacistes
suprémacistes pardon qui s'empare de
cette de cette puissance médiatique ça
c'est nouveau la question du coc vide la
question de la comment dire de
l'effondrement des dés on va dire des
programmes de santé qui fait qu' il ya
aussi beaucoup de problèmes liés à la
santé mentale d'eau qui est dans la rue
qui peut faire quoi qui a accès à quoi
aux états unis c'est ça les grandes
questions après qu'il y ait un jeune
homme de 18 ans qui explosent à un
moment ce n'est que la suite logique de
deux forces sociales politiques et
historiques qui sont à l'oeuvre depuis
des années c'est à dire qu'on peut pas
on peut pas seulement limité cette
action à la l'idée d'un loup solitaire
combien de loup solitaire faudra-t-il
dans l'histoire des états unis pour
comprendre que la question est
structurelle et gênerait que pour
rebondir sur ce que vient de dire
mahboula soumahoro c'est effectivement
un phénomène structurel il y a tout de
même vous disiez ça existe depuis
longtemps mais il y a tout de même cette
résurgence aujourd'hui du suprématisme
blanc aux états unis liées justement de
ces émission sur fox news peut-être qui
alimente les théories complotistes
notamment de ceux de ce présentateur
qu'on appelle tucker de carcassonne pour
ce qu'ils ne connaissent pas qui
véhicule un peu ces complots on a parlé
aussi beaucoup de donald trump qui
véhiculait aussi ces complots est ce que
aujourd'hui ça devient une sorte de
banalités et ce suprématisme blanc
justement en profite
pas tellement parce qu'encore je
voudrais préfère préciser que dans les
années il ya 100 ans dans les années
vingt du 20e siècle les massacres
étaient pro n'est subventionné par des
organisations très riches comme le kkk 2
le clic axe crème
les gens qui se cachait derrière leur
l'heure lors des draps et finalement et
qui cible et les noirs mais d'une façon
très organisée alors qu'aujourd'hui
c'est ça a l'air d'être un peu plus
aléatoire et de blâmer un tracker
carlsen ou internet seul
ça ne s'adresse pas ça n'aborde pas la
vraie question la fréquentation ces
états unis la vraie donc ça veut dire
c'est un loup il est vrai que la vraie
question suit six collèges ya des rires
des loups solitaires
partout mais qui sont célèbres dans le
cinéma dans la culture américaine on
prend on applaudit le type qui qui qui
se venge seul contre la société
cc très hollywood tout ça c'est très
clean eastwood a donc
qu'un seul américain est un des leviers
c'est ce que vous voulez dire oui oui
oui et du paranoïa et mais encore trop
carson c'est un comédien c'est un type
qui profitent de la haine bien sûr il
garde beaucoup beaucoup d'argent en
faisant sa comédie mais les gens qui
voudraient voir une vraie suprématie
blanche c'est pas tort car seul ce sont
des gens dans l'ombre et ils sont
minoritaires rappelez vous qu'il ya pas
très longtemps en avait on avait un
président noir qui a été réélu avec une
majorité une grande majorité alors on ne
peut pas dire que l'amérique s'est
fondamentalement raciste mais il ya
quand même c'est ce phénomène américain
et je dirais un peu psychologique de du
tube du type marginal qui ce qui se sent
poussé au pied au pied du mur
et qu'ils se vengent françois durpaire
volet rsa c'est ses traits c'est très
américain culturel qui culturellement et
c'est très hollywood sait cellou et bars
hollywood alors attendez c'est à dire
père vous réponds non oui enfin c'est ce
que c'est pas marginal en fait on peut
comparer avec l'histoire très bien on
peut le premier crime ed fries les aides
prime si on peut parler du génocide
amérindiens c'étaient des crimes raciaux
les lynchages ils étaient quotidiens ça
c'est une mais après quand on parle de
jalousie du raciste contemporain le fbi
a défini cette prime et le définit sa
est en fait des statistiques depuis 1991
il ya cette année plus de 8000 crimes de
haine c'est un record depuis 1991 donc
il s'agit pas de dire on peut dire oui
effectivement j'ai aussi des amérindiens
c'était très grave et puis les lynchages
il était très grave il n'y a que depuis
une certaine et plus de la moitié alors
65% sur les réclames s'est pas
uniquement des crimes raciaux parmi ceux
là c'est 65 % de crimes raciaux parmi
ces 65 % de crémation c'est plus de la
moitié afro américains qui sont touchés
par exemple un tiers des universités de
tradition afro-américaine de collège ont
reçu une alerte à la bombe au cours de
cette année donc ça veut dire qu'il ya
des phénomènes contemporains ont parlé
d'un instant donald trump ou savait que
de d'octobre à décembre 2010 cette
élection de donald trump il ya une
hausse de 26 % des aides qu à mende et
des crimes liés à ça alors après ce qui
ressort de l'histoire du pays s'est uni
où il se passe le crime il se passe dans
un quartier afro américains ça c'est ça
qui est anachronique qu'on puisse
aujourd'hui dire east side buffalo c'est
que des noirs américains c'est à dire
que ces afro américains et ça c'est lié
aux reds mais c'est lié à des décennies
et des décennies de décès greg de
ségrégation et ce à la presse américaine
va pas en parler elle va dire
effectivement ce sont des
ségrégationnistes ça va beaucoup moins
parler du racisme structurel qui fait
que hausse moment dans l'urbanisme
américain oui c'est peut-être compliqué
parce que il ya des questions raciales
et des questions cydia la pauvreté et
toutes ces questions là elles sont
imbriquées mais il ya les deux choses il
ya la partie émergée de l'iceberg
ccc 8000 et sprint et puis il la partie
aussi de racisme systémique mahboula son
origine que vous êtes d'accord à ce que
vient de dire françois durpaire sur
serait ce racisme systémique aux états
unis ce structurelles ce que je dis
enfin si on reprend ce que vient de dire
françois durpaire si on est à buffalo et
qu'on veut tuer des africains-américains
on sait où les trouver on sait d où les
trouver spatialement et géographique
mais la ségrégation n'explique pas
forcément un acte comme celui ci non
parce que nous avons parlé de la
structure c'est à dire qu' il ya des
quartiers c'est à dire qu'on n'a pas
besoin de faire toute la ville pour
tomber sur un africain-américain quand
quand on veut en tuer un et d'ailleurs
je les ai laissé faire pour revenir
justement sur le criminel il était allé
faire un repérage est allé plusieurs
fois il est allé ou alors on marche sur
place passez la journée donc il a rossé
réponse est que dans l'organisation
urbaine or on sait que les
africains-américains élan parle d'un
quartier modeste ans jeudi elle peut
avoir des quartiers africains-américains
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus riche en
tout cas dans ce sens dans ce cas de
figure
l'arn un reflet de la ségrégation
structurelle parce qu'on parle de
buffalo en plus de l'état de new york on
est dans le nord n'est pas dans le sud
il ya quand même tradition démocrate
libéral où l'on voit la ville pendant
longtemps les états unis ont voulu
croire enfin le nord des etats-unis a
voulu croire qu il était moins raciste
que le sud et ça on le sait depuis
depuis la fin des esclavages depuis la
fin du 19e siècle le début du xxème
siècle que cette question de la
catégorisation raciale et des actes
racistes elle touche l'ensemble des
états unis et que ce soit pour les
communautés raciales ou les communautés
aussi qui regroupe des orientations
sexuelles particulière il ya des crimes
de haine qui visent les communautés lgbt
guyaz plus enfin je veux dire ont su de
tous et peut-être que l'accès sur les
domaines mais les démons gradient avec
le 21e siècle 20e siècle les réseaux
sociaux non il ya les noms il a gardé
trop la convention peut-être aussi il ya
là la transformation de la société tout
à l'heure on a évoqué donc les
évolutions démocrate graphique est
évidemment oui en 2050 les blancs se
deviendront minoritaires aux états unis
ça c'est une ça c'est un fait un fait
scientifique 1 c'est un fait statistique
maintenant qu'est ce que ça veut dire de
là comment dire la position des blancs
par rapport à cette angoisse
communautaire est ce que cette angoisse
communautaire doit se traduire en actes
violents à chaque fois qu'il ya une
évolution à la fin de l' esclavage
l'évolution enfin l'émergence des
premiers groupes suprématistes blancs
sont liées à l'entrée des anciens
esclaves sur le marché du travail et
donc la compétition économique ou le
collègue qui est avec nous depuis new
york a parlé d d afrique américains qui
étaient utilisés pour briser les grèves
pub dans la période de
l'entre-deux-guerres
donc c'est ça aussi la question et ans
assistant d'assurer des peurs ses
tenants sacrés de la compétition et la
commission économie et de la rivalité
est donc on se sent menacé on se sent
menacée déposséder au lieu d'interroger
le système qui organise
tout c'est toutes ces phases en fait
john rich avant d'écouter oui vous allez
réagir mais une question encore sur
justement ce jeune homme
petit peu cheap petite précision
statistique comme on parle de
statistiques c'est ironiquement la
proportion des noirs par rapport avec la
population totale est en baisse
alors ce sont les latinos qui sont en
hausse alors c'est tordu c'est vraiment
tordu c'est vraiment enduit alors c'est
tordu en tout cas au point que
christopher est donc le directeur du fbi
à huile a dressé le constat de cette
menace du suprématisme blanc pardon de
revenir à cela tout de même john rich
depuis longtemps et en fait on a envie
de se dire tout de même que le fbi a et
ponts passé totalement à côté de ce
criminel qui est quand même qui s'est
rendu sur place pour faire il a 18 ans
en plus donc très jeune et il s'est
rendu sur place pour faire une sorte de
prendre des photos examiné effectivement
l'emplacement c'était vraiment prémédité
c'était sur les réseaux d'ailleurs sur
un certain nombre de plateformes c'est
le washington post qui le dit
aujourd'hui qui a eu accès justement à
800 messages de ce tueur sûr
une plateforme de réseau social
donc on se demande comment aux états
unis effectivement on lutte contre cela
alors que effectivement c'était quand
même clair qu'il allait qu'il allait
commettre ce crime
oui
effectivement et mais ce qui est
vraiment vraiment déchirant c'est que
ces jeunes hommes
avec déjà un record à c'est un dossier
assez assez clair sur ses intentions
soit permis d'acheter un fusil
automatique dans un magasin près de chez
lui sans questions sans question alors
oui on peut pas empêcher la folie
interdire la folie en amérique ni en
france mais on peut quand même
poursuivre les pistes et on ne fait pas
on ne peut pas pour des raisons
politiques si on soulève biya a l'air de
de soupçonner trop de gens de regarder
trop trop de proches les
soi disant terroristes
trop souvent
il y aura absolument une réaction de
tucker carlson et d'être en piste ce
qu'ils vont dire voilà l'état qui qui
met son poids qui pose son poids sur la
population
virtu vertueuse et c'est vraiment une
question politique et médiatique
maintenant on ne veut pas se présenter
comme trop autoritaire envers d'être en
piste et vers les racistes alors que
parce que bien sûr il ya beaucoup de
policiers beaucoup de flics boucle jean
joseph pia qui sont tout à fait d'accord
avec trump que la race blanche et menacé
que le petit bonhomme du coin qui a
perdu son emploi à cause de l'alena ou
de l'accord avec la chine à cause de
délocalisation est menacé
alors il faut il faut se taire est là on
va écouter c est laisser
oui vous parlais justement on voit bien
que cette sphère politique bien sûr ce
sujet l'occurrence celui de la vente des
armes aux états unis ce n'est pas la
première fois qu'on en parle et joe
biden vont se souvient de barack obama
qui s'est exprimé nombre de fois
justement pour la régulation de ces
armes aux états unis ce tueur avait
effectivement posséder une arme
automatique on va écouter joe biden donc
un c'était à buffalo il ya quelques
instants
décevant
ce venin cette violence ne peuvent pas
être l'histoire de notre époque nous ne
pouvons pas le permettre je ne suis pas
naïf je sais qu'il y aura d'autres
tragédies nous ne pourrons pas y
échapper
mais il ya certaines choses que nous
pouvons faire nous pouvons empêcher les
armes d'assaut de circuler dans les rues
françaises père c'est l'arlésienne en
fait dire aux états unis cette question
de régulation des armes joe biden
peut-il aujourd'hui avec cette petite
majorité qu'il a à la chambre des
représentants est alors encore plus
vraiment très très petit au sénat ce qui
peut faire passer une loi de régulation
des armes aux états unis donc fédéral
oui ce qu'il faudrait c'est une loi qui
vérifie les antécédents on est on sait
bien qu'il ya le deuxième amendement on
va pas supprimer les armes aux italie
vérifier les antécédents déjà c'est
impossible il faudrait une super
majorité cr 60 c'est impossible puis en
plus vous savez même sur ce sujet les
démocrates vont à ne pas être au complet
parce que
lorsqu'il faut bien quand même retenir
c'est que la plupart des tireurs de
masse ou en commun une chose ils ont
acheté leurs armes légalement de 1966 à
2019 c'est les chiffres qu'on à 77% des
tireurs de masse c'est-à-dire quatre
victimes ont acheté légalement leurs
armes dans le cas présent le tueur de
buffalo il va au vintage files il
demande est là 18 ans peu importe et il
demanda bushmaster x et unix n 15 qui
exactement la copie de la r15 il rentre
chez lui puisque c'est comme types
d'armes c'est une arme automatique c'est
une arme de guerre en motos matic alors
est quand même une loi d'état formidable
qui permet de la bride et donc on
l'achète et rentre chez lui il prend une
perceuse électrique
il retire le bout on de retenue qui
permet de brider sa capacité et il va me
falloir est qu une arme de guerre comme
en irak le même ar 15 comme en irak cela
dit c'est abominable partout hein mais
c'est une arme de guerre et il faut
quand même préciser une chose si vous
êtes arlésienne c'est pas que arlésienne
c'est de pire en pire huit des vingt
fusillade de masse les plus meurtrières
de toute l'histoire du pays c'est depuis
2014 donc on est là dans une
accentuation du phénomène du fait sans
doute aussi de là j'allais dire de
l'horreur de ce type d'armes du fait
aussi de la détermination de ce type de
criminels et de l'effet copycat je vous
rappelle vous disiez que ce tu ce tueur
le fbi a qu'a t'il fait il ya un article
sur son blog en avril où il dit le fbi
haye ne maquera pas c'est sans doute
qu'il veut que j'aille jusqu'au bout
imaginez sans il imagine qui les
soutient par le fbi est pas ce que je
dis j'ai tellement écrit sur tous les
réseaux que si le fbi ya une matra pas
c'est sans doute que c'était râpé gamin
18 ans il cache ses armées il dit
j'espère que ma maman ne va pas trouver
mes armes il fait une infraction au code
de la route et j'espère que mon papa ne
va pas le trouver et que je vais pouvoir
aller massacrer des gens donc on est là
dans kz2 complètement ahurissant l'école
belle école ça a essayé de faire son
travail parce qu'il avait il avait dit
je me suicider ou jeu tuer des gens on
avait fait une évaluation psychiatrique
et au fait ça n'a pas ça n'a pas eu de
suite au final mahmoud est vivant
enfin j'espère c'est quand on peut on
peut comparer comment dire ce cas de
figure avec tous les cas de figure 2
on va dire de meurtre public ou de mort
en direct face aux autorités
étasuniennes donc là ça va devenir très
très difficile de 2 comment dire de
passer à côté de la question du racisme
et encore une fois du racisme structurel
aux états unis et sur cette question des
armes justement barack obama est revenu
à la charge un certain nombre de fois
joe biden encore aujourd'hui donc veut
revenir à la charge c'est peine perdue
c'est alors qu'une partie est perdue je
pense qu'il y aura de démobilisation et
d'un activisme réalisé autour de cette
question du deuxième amendement mais
peut-être qu'il faut revenir aux
fondamentaux et rappelez peut-être à
l'auditoire française qui est le
deuxième amendement le deuxième
amendement fait partie du document qui
s'appelle de bill of rights et c'est
sacré on parle d'une constitution qui
date de 1787 aux états unis en france
par exemple on est sous la vème
république on n'est pas sous la deuxième
troisième ou quatrième constitution on
est sous en fin aux états unis le
document juridique qui fait foi dans le
pays est un document qui né de la
révolution américaine donc on ne change
pas comme ça les dix premiers
amendements sont des amendements sacré
et donc c'est pourri des possibles pour
toutes les personnes qui comme on dire
s'oppose à la régulation des des armes
et la limitation de l'utilisation des
armes aux états unis il est facile de
prôner ou de mettre en avant le
caractère sacré de la constitution des
as tu des états unis et de bill of
rights même si on pourrait très
facilement rappeler que ce deuxième
amendement il entre en vigueur au moment
où les états unis sortent d'une guerre
donc de 7 ans contre la grande bretagne
sont en revanche commencer leur grande
comment dire expansion territoriale donc
quand on parle de l'état libre de free
state c'est le terme qui apparaît dans
le deuxième amendement on parle d'une
nation d'une jeune nation en danger qui
veut se défendre est une jeune nation
qui veut aussi élargir ses frontières
donc est-ce qu'on en est au même moment
de l'histoire des états unis sont non
non on avait il faut le faire comprendre
à john rich pourquoi ce deuxième
amendement est il aussi sacré
mais c'est pas seulement l'expansion
territoriale qui était en jeu il y avait
aussi la peur d'être on voulait pas que
les soldats britanniques puissent
habiter chez vous ça vous arrange le
suivre entré chez vous et insister à
dire que maintenant c'est ma maison
alors il ya il ya toutes ces traditions
anti militaires anti état qui joue dans
le dans les émotions qui soutiennent le
deuxième amendement mais je ne comprends
pas pourquoi
les politiciens sérieux et bein
finalement c'est pas un politicien
sérieux à mon avis ne prendre pas une
modification du deuxième amendement ça
prendrait
ça serait vraiment pénible ça prend
trois quarts des états pour approuver
une modification de 2 de la constitution
que ces conflits ont joué au moins
commencer commencer un débat et dire ok
dans l'état de new york on va on va
proposer une modification du deuxième
amendement qui interdit les armes les
armes de guerre ou je ne sais pas trop
bien démissionner le débat j'ai inventé
ça sur place et comme excuse excusez moi
je dis majliss al mabhouh là en plus
c'est vrai que barack obama on se
souvient moi je n'ai pas j'en ai pendant
j'en ai pas envie j'en ai pas entendu
par des
régulations sienne un activisme odeur de
dubaï nous la soirée mais aux états unis
sauf qu'ils n'ont pas gagné que sa
demande du courage politique pour les
produits nos normes et politiciennes
et vous répond attendait que bahreïn n'a
pas que bach abide n'a pas donné pas mal
de courage politique
non mais il a pas la majorité n'ont qu
s'il avait le courage il montrait il
monte il monte très haut ils monteraient
au créneau et dirait
on a été courageux nouveau c'est la
constitution
pas du tout
alors la cen-sad il avait très peur ils
avaient très peur on a entendu les
politiques américains ou depuis ailleurs
depuis les des analyseurs vous répond on
a attendu les politiques américains
depuis les dernières heures regrettait
alors c'est même pas proposer
une législation en matière d'armes c'est
au regretté qu'il ne puisse pas le faire
nancy pelosi enfin ils ont tous horizons
ils ont tous exprimé ça mais ils ont
dévié problème du parce que appartement
on vous dit le port d'armes c'est
compliqué c'est impossible on n'a pas de
majorité pour le faire là il ya un crime
raciste je suis désolé à l'époque des
lynchages puisqu'on a commencé par
parler de l'histoire américaine les
blancs racistes n'utilisez pas des armes
de guerre donc ça veut dire que même si
on met les armes de guerre de côté les
lynchages ont toujours existé sahara
continue donc là il ya peut-être
spécifiquement des mesures à faire pour
limiter ces crimes racistes est ce que
c'est possible je vous donne un exemple
très concret 82% des suspects liés au
crime de haine entre 2005 et 2010 9
n'ont pas été poursuivis par la justice
donc là il ya une proposition très
concrète que les procureurs fédéraux
soient sensibilisés à cette
problématique pour que ces personnes
soient alors évidemment dans le cas du
tueur de buffalo dix morts etc mais je
parle de l' alerte à la bombe je parle
de la lettre d'insultés racistes de
toutes ces choses qui sont à l'intérieur
du crest de l est qui doivent être
suivis en justice ça c'est une
proposition extrêmement concrètes et
peut-être d'un mot je vois que le temps
passe ne pas faire croire non plus que
c'est spécifiquement afro américains on
sort d'une période où la population
asiatique américaine a souffert
d'ailleurs dans la modernité j'allais
dire entre guillemets du crime de haine
le premier c'est 1982 c'est vincent chin
et les deux suprémaciste blanc vous
savez pourquoi ils le tuent cet
américain d'origine chinoise parce que
ils en ont marre des fermetures
industrielles dans l'automobile et ils
s'en prennent à l'industrie japonaise on
dit c'est un américain d'origine
chinoise quel rapport avec le japon
là on a encore eu la semaine dernière un
attentat dans un magasin coréen pourquoi
vous le savez parce que kovy de 19
donald trump a parlé d'un virus chinois
on a ça sur toutes les chaînes d'extrême
droite américaine virus chinois et donc
les coréens et même d'ailleurs les
américains d'origine chinoise n'ont pas
à subir plus que ça mais vous avez là
non seulement ces criminels évidemment
c'est complètement idiot et vous avez un
sociologue américain russe l'anc est
très intéressant pour dire qu'il ya une
matrice global mais que chaque
communauté aussi subi et souffre de ce
racisme c'est un problème de justice
maboul à ce moment vous souvenez
s'éteint c'est un problème de justice
est un problème d'égalité d'équité de
protection et la protection équivalente
pour tous les citoyens comme je le
disais tout à l'heure qu'on tue des
personnes issues des communautés lgbt qu
ia ou des juifs ou des asiatiques un peu
plus en ce moment des latinos des
africains américains enfin on parle de
vraiment de l'ensemble des communautés
qui constituent cette nation étasunienne
c'est à dire qu'on n'est pas seulement
dans le dans la question de
l'immigration est de 2,2 ce pays qui se
verrait comme recevoir actuellement des
vagues non on parle de personnes qui
constitue depuis des siècles cette
nation étasunienne donc il y à un
traitement inégalitaire et qui est très
ancien ce traitement inégalitaire oui on
peut remonter aux populations
autochtones
on peut on peut aller jusqu'aux comment
dire jusqu'au lynchage de la fin du 19e
siècle au début du 20e siècle des
attaques contre les populations latine
ex entre les deux guerres enfin
volailles des crimes racistes aux états
unis on a eu avant que le que le l'état
fédéral ne parviennent à mettre en avant
cette idée de crimes de haine c'est à
dire que les crimes ont précédés mais ça
veut la qualification je
pourrais quand même un jeu françois
parent dont john rich justement une
réaction sur ce problématique de justice
aux etats-unis est-ce que c'est
effectivement est-ce que ce qui
effectivement commettre ce type de
crimes ne sont justement pas vraiment
jugé que c'est ça aussi la question
ben on est jugés s'ils ont comme commet
un crime aussi spectaculaire que celui
du buffalo il sera incarcéré pendant le
restant de sa vie sans doute
mais le système de justice de systèmes
juridiques aux états unis est
complètement biaisé contre les noirs
c'est vraiment ça c'est historique et la
police en général est dominé par des
blancs et on voit après un an deux ans
après le meurtre de george clooney est
toujours des noirs
vraiment assassiné par des policiers
blancs
pour des raisons aléatoire c'est
absolument incroyable ce qui se passe
aux etats unis mais rien ne change sauf
que ce qui est vraiment gênant c'est
d'entendre les politiciens appelé à
l'unité après les massacres c'est pas
sérieux c'est simplement pas sérieux il
faudrait attaquer juridiquement
les processus tordu de la justice
américaine on ne le fait pas ya pas d
c'est un peu insérée dans le système
pénal bien sûr nous avons 50 états avec
50 code criminel mais quand même bon
j'ai déjà d'autres actions si chacun des
écoles que que dire que de pardonnez moi
le bleu mer de buffalo a demandé lui un
contrôle des armes ne serait ce que sur
sa ville il pourrait le faire
théoriquement
oui oui il y aura bien sûr un procès
entamées par le lobby des armes à feu et
dans deux ans la cour suprême
probablement va abroger la loi a beau
polo mais il faut quand même faire un
effort mais il faut faire un effort
aussi au niveau fédéral et nous n'avons
pas un président qui a le courage
vraiment
d'affronter le lobby des armes à feu
quel est le président
non il y en a eu un courageux à vos yeux
la tension va regarder aller au ciel
mikami carter
entraîna la tension entre les états
le courage m françois durpaire vous
réagissez en appel
d'un mot peut-être terminée sur une note
positive parce qu'on a parlé 50 minutes
des suprémacistes blancs il faut parler
de tous les américains qui sont pas des
suprémacistes blancs c'est la sociologie
américaine je parle sous le contrôle de
ma boule à vous explique quand même que
depuis ces dernières années il ya des
indicateurs positifs en matière de
tolérance raciale notamment sur la
question des mariages interraciaux ce a
considérablement évolué alors ça dépend
des communautés en a en tout cas dire
est-ce que ça c'est important il ya
aussi la question de la représentation
des minorités dans les séries au cinéma
etc ça a beaucoup changé vous rappeler
en 2014 avait cette étude qui montrait
que 89 % des femmes noires étaient
présentés comme des femmes agressives
bataille et des productrices afro
américaine vous avez déjà derrière nous
il ya des évolutions oui peut-être que
l'évolution je suis d'accord sur
certains points de la place l'évolution
majeure pour moi c'est la fin de
l'impunité et c'est ces débats nationaux
et internationaux avant ces crimes là se
passer dans l'impunité la plus totale
donc il ya un progrès de ce côté là il
ya un mini progrès et il en faut
beaucoup plus john wick le mot de la fin
il ya un mini progrès bon
j'ai parlé tout à l'heure de l'élection
de barack obama c'est un énorme progrès
connu demande à un président noir qui a
qui a été élu pour deux mandats c'est
extraordinaire
c'est c'était impensable il ya 60 ans 70
ans alors on fait des progrès mais pour
contrôler les fous et les racistes il
faut il faut prendre des mesures plus
sérieuses pour ça il faudrait il nous
faut un volant une volonté au niveau
fédéral qui commence par le président la
maison blanche département de justice et
il en serait peur
les lycéens fait merci john aurait des
magasins simply connaître la sécession
de l'état fédéral a voulu sans pause et
on sait ce que ça a coûté aux états unis
d'amérique merci en tout cas d'avoir été
avec nous à john et moi car ça vous
étiez avec ton direct de new-york persia
vous mahboula soumahoro merci d'avoir
été avec nous merci françois durpaire
votre dès le dernier livre c'est chez
glénat je le signale encore merci à vous
tous de nous avoir suivi on reste avec
nous sur france24 bien sûr